[Music]
hi boys um well it's my real pleasure
introduce sabrina russian she is a PhD
candidate at Carnegie Mellon University
working with super Joseph and she spent
the summer looking at applying deep
learning to single celled a tubular
using she'll say using the variational
autoencoders to try to understand the
heterogeneity of tumors from single-cell
data hi everyone has no who mentioned
I'm Sabrina Hardy R P finishing third
year PhD student in at Carnegie Mellon
University a computational biology
department so in this summer intern
project we looked into a single cell
tumor data and we know like tumor comes
from very heterogeneous landscapes so we
wanted to find whether the can we
identify the underlying heterogeneity
from that singles of data so this is a
brief outline of the talk motivation
method and then results and discussion
so next first motivation as I mentioned
inter tumor inter to more heterogeneity
means is very one of the challenging
things when you want to decipher a tumor
evolution from first subject so what
happens is that malignant cells even if
they're coming from a single tumor
they'll have a very distinct genomic
profile so in terms of their gene
expression values or copy number profile
or mutations like each cell will have
something different so earlier what
happened when people use sequencing they
used to do bulk sequencing where you
actually put a bunch of cells together
and then sequence all the cells together
not like at an individual level so what
happens is there when you do bulk
sequencing wrong of such tumors it
actually averages out their genomic
profile so you lose their heterogeneity
information so next came singles or
sequencing which is very important if
you want to unmask whether the
underlying heterogeneity or difference
of these different malignant cells but
then single cell data comes with its own
sets of computer
challenges since we are sequencing at
single-cell so that quantity that your
sequence is very little so it the data
is actually very noisy and sparse by
sparse I mean like lot of there will be
lot of genes that are in low quantities
so it will not be detected in many cells
so hints even though it's expressed in a
low level it will it will be a
completely zero in many cells so that
there would be like dropout and sparse
so it's it becomes very hard to like to
extract meaningful but biologically
meaningful features so that is the
expression data then again comes the
copy number and mutation data from DNA
sequencing so to estimate her to have
like high fidelity estimation of
mutation and copy number profiles at a
single cell level you need very high
depth sequencing so which is not always
possible even if it's possible you will
only be able to sequence like only a
couple of cells not along not a large
cohort to make your to analyze the data
so here we are using our variational
auto encoder to learn a latent
representation of the single cell data
that is coherent with the underlying
biology and also generalize enough to
the different types of genomic data
different types I mean are nesic
expression data and also meet a copy
number data from DNA sequencing so we
know auto-encoders are this
multi-layered perceptron are neural
networks that learn their own definition
of the data in a completely unsupervised
manner but information or Auto encoded
the concept of this unsupervised deep
learning is merged with the observation
inference where you actually instead of
generating an unconstraint
representation of the data we assume
that the latent representation is
actually coming from an underlying
distribution it's if you are think about
it it's like how scientists are observed
like nature you observe or nature of
phenomena and you want to know what is
the underlying law that is governing
them so it's kind of like that we want
to learn any presentation instead of
learning unconstrained presentation we
want to learn actually the distribution
that the latent representation is coming
from
so here this is the structure of the
auto encoder so you have the first input
there is there a number of genes and
then we have three intermediate layers
and then the last the latent layer so
how many how many nodes in each layer
and how many layers you wanted that can
be user parameter for the package so for
the further results that we'll show I
have used three date and dimension and
that particular layer so here instead of
actually encoding the latent represent
shouldn't sit directly we are actually
including for the sample mean and sample
variance and we're learning the the
distribution given the input data once
we have that we can sample Z from that
learnt probablistic so it is kind of
giving you a probabilistic
encoding of the input data space and and
then there is a complimentary decoding
decoder network when we learn the
structure we learn it as a whole like
encoding and decoding but we are
actually where we're learning the
parameters of the model but we are
actually interested in the latent
representation at this sridham
three-dimensional netting representation
of the data so that is a brief overview
of the algorithm that we are using so we
have actually had three types of
datasets that we have tested our method
one a first gene expression analysis we
have three three different single-cell
artistic gene expression data of with
our first one is with over 4,000 cells
second on over 6,000 cells and the last
one over 2,000 and all of them has like
23 k genes then we have copy number to
copy number data sets from DNA
sequencing data these two are actually
xenograft samples and first sample has
260 and the second sample is 250 for our
cells these two xenograft samples can be
our sequenced at a very low depth so
point 0 5 X and we can see that even
with this very low depth copy number
estimation we can still get some
biological meaningful output from the
data and then our last we wanted to
quantify our performance of our proposed
method with some
the existing techniques so that's why
for that we have used synthetic gene
expression data set where we know
actually how many clusters are in there
and can compute some quantitative metric
to analyze the methods
so first the oligodendroglioma data set
where the data set contains a mixture of
malignant and non mannequin cells upon
we pass the data through our auto
encoder we can see there is a clear
separation between the malignant and non
mannequin micro clear macrophage cells
next we wanted to see our goal was to
unmask tumor heterogeneity so we wanted
to investigate more manikin cells so
next we pass the malignant cells the
relative expression of the malignant
cells only to the autoencoder and we get
these nice structures so we are getting
a bifurcation like structure like a V
like structure where you see that cells
are put on to like two two different
types of cells are coming out and
they're put on the two different arms of
the restructure so the first one here
the data that the paper originally
reported they also computed
differentiation and lineage metric for
each of the cells based on a set of
signature genes and the set of control
genes so to show that that the two
different types of cells are indeed put
onto two different arms we have actually
colored our scatter plot using their
matrix like the first one is the lineage
school which shows which cells are all
your like and which cells are Astro like
like these started two different cell
types that are present in the data and
we see a nice separation and then we
also have the differentiation matrix
that is which cells are further
differentiated and which cells are in
more stem like so we do see our SM so
looking at the structure we thought the
more stem like cells should be near the
neck of the bifurcation and we do see
that the more our stem like cells are
indeed put in the nail in this side so
this so this actually shows how the
auto-encoder without using the prior
knowledge we are actually fishing out
what are the underlying
humor heterogeneity and how these two
populations are related to each other
it's actually showing that that even
though there are two different types
cell types prison they're actually
coming from the same lineage so this is
with the signature genes only next we
wanted to see whether we can find same
kind of structure without using any
signature it just automatically
selecting of selecting some cells based
on maybe coefficient of variation or
average expression level or something so
this is based on average expression
level with top 5,000 genes 5,000 otto
selected genes and we can still see that
it gives a good separation of the two
different types of cell population next
we wanted to compare with other methods
whether they can capture the same truth
or not so the first one is the TSN a TSN
is really popular now to do reduce
dimension for of high mean high
dimensional data and has been used in
many single cell processing and artistic
processing datasets but here what
usually does it does show a separation
but it's still showing the separation of
different samples that the tumors are
coming from but it's not actually
capturing what is the state of the each
cell like it's not showing any distinct
differentiation between the two types of
cells then again we have the PCA so PCA
can shows like somewhat separation but
it's not the structure is not as
distinct as we have for our auto encoder
so next data said that is next data
sister astrocytoma with over 6,000 cells
here again we see clear separation of
the malignant in figure a malignant and
non malignant cells and then again we
yeah used only we passed only the
malignant creative expressions through
the auto-encoders and for this
particular data set the authors didn't
compute like the matrix that we had for
the earlier data set so to know like of
what we are getting at we I plotted it
on top of the matrix from the previous
data set so the solid dots actually from
the previous data sets and marked with
the
translation score and we do see that
most of the astrocytomas their malignant
astrocytoma cells are actually falling
in the stem like region so when we when
I went back to the original paper to see
whether it makes sense or not we see
that they do mention the most the most
of the cells in that data set is
actually in a more intermediate States
so it's actually capturing it's
accurately capturing that their
statement as well so this is another
data set which is the Leukemia dataset
and here we we see a separation of cell
lines k562 cell line and the other cells
but we are not seeing a distinct
separation based on the BCRA so these
are gene mutation status of each cells
so we are not seeing a distinct
separation between between these status
but we do see a blunt v like structure
probably it is catching or something
else like that is common to all these
type of cells so it needs this
particular validation is actually needs
more biological analysis to see what is
what are we we see our trajectory but
what are we actually seeing biologically
how relevant it is it needs further work
I just wanted to show the plot of this
result so next we analyze synthetic
datasets so in the synthetic data set we
have 500 cells treated for each so we
have 3000 genes and cells are coming
from five different clusters so each
cluster will have 100 cells also so here
for this particular one there is
actually 2.5 k cells that are actually
representative of the cluster and 590
cells when we pass it through the
auto-encoder
we see a very good separation of the
five clusters and when we estimate the
number of clusters using a Gaussian
mixture model we can see that the
auto-encoder actually correctly predicts
there are five clusters which none of
the other ones do t-sne
like captures free but the PCA is only
one and also we computed the adjusted
random index for all of the cases and we
see that we have the maximum 0.98 for
our auto encoder compared to the other
tube next we increased the number amount
of noises genes to 2500 in out of 3,000
so only 500 genes are actually signal of
the actual clusters and here the
autoencoder is actually picking up four
clusters not but still much with a much
better adjusted random index score than
the compared to the rest of one so you
can see a PCA is just a blob she has a
nice um separation between two but not
so much so the their score is really
known then we also did some companies
and so I showed you what autoencoders
structure we used in the in our paper
and then we try to see whether we can
like are much shorter much if we remove
the inter some of the intermediate
layers how does it affect it does get
faster but not by it's not by much suits
3.43 and i would say it's not that
expensive as a run time but we do get a
very bitter AR i compared to the other
structures and also both of the
structures are faster than t-sne and TSN
has lower matric next result that i'm
going to show is the copy number so this
is DNA sequencing data so the earlier
ones for RNA sequencing data so this is
a DNA sequencing data which i'm showing
the two samples on top of superimposed
on each other so then on both our
xenograft press tumor samples you can
consider xenograft for as a later time
point of xenograft 3 what we can see
here is that in xenograft 3 there are
two different clusters that are like one
major clusters and one
minor cluster of the cells and when you
progress after some treatment when you
progress to the later time point at
xenograft for the minor cluster actually
vanishes so upon projecting in that
space you can clearly see that which
which cast so once we know that we can
actually study those cells which which
properties made those cells not
progressed into the next time points but
the major clusters and we can see also
from for what is the biological
relevance of these clusters you see this
is the copy number profile of the
xenograft three samples where you see
that there is a small cluster of cells
that has like twice the copy number and
this chromosome compared to the rest of
the cells so that is actually what is
captured in the small cluster here so
this group of cells are actually not
progressing to the next time point so as
I mentioned in the beginning of the
slide one of the key problem of single
cell data is dropout so it means like
some of the genes will not have any
signal in many of the cells so we wanted
to see how robust the auto-encoder
representation is compared to the
dropout events so for that we have used
a synthetic data with 2.5 k noisy genes
out of 3000 genes and we can see that
both pca and TS any after increasing
number of dropouts of couple of
percentage they actually doesn't capture
more than one clusters so they just
captured just one cluster so that's why
the ERI score has dropped down to zero
even after increasing the percentage of
dropout more than 5% or so but
autoencoder is it is degrading the
performance watch but compared to the
other two it's much better so up until
like 10 percent we still see points
close to point 7 and if we increase the
number of dropouts to 50 percent like
half of the genes are actually dropout
and we see around like 0.3 or 0.4 so
it's still differentiating the clusters
maybe not as well as the earlier case
but it's still showing it can identify
the clusters and can somewhat make some
differentiation so compared to the other
two it's much better so to summarize
what I have done we have proposed a new
way of extracting useful features with
biological significance from single-cell
data
nice thing about it is it's completely
unsupervised I know it requires minimal
pre-processing of the data it's fairly
robust to the raw outs and we have
developed a Python package and that will
be distributed as an open-source package
in future so here all the results I have
shown as tree dementia are as has three
relating dimension I started with three
latent dimension just to visualize many
results and see and and then I saw that
it's actually showing so I didn't
actually go beyond the three dimension
later point but I would actually aren't
being interested to investigate more
latent dimensions because in the tree
demon in the tree let in dimensions we
actually can see differentiation between
different cell types but maybe if we go
beyond that maybe some other dimensions
will capture some other aspects of the
heterogeneity such as tumor
microenvironment
or how the cells will respond to treat
treatment response and so on and so
forth and also I showed you some results
that I like we are seeing that kind of
like trajectory or differentiation paths
but it definitely needs more biologic
more research on what is the biological
significance of that structure that we
are learning so for the CML data i still
have to do a lot more on that and so
these are the two immediate main goals
of the current work that i'm i want to
do and soon some references and yeah so
that's pretty much my work that i have
done in the last relics
[Applause]
any questions
yes it's equal self-discipline saying
still basic research or is it been used
translational applications are people
actually using it to the clinic today
you're it's a religious basic research
yeah this one it's just basically I
don't think they're yeah I don't think
this in clinical research chemical
that's Sophia yeah and why are you gonna
publish a paper on this as well so yeah
we have actually finished tracking the
draft
okay so just polishing up and then
probably something anyway is it possible
to interrogate the transformation into
the latent space underlying biological
model where you have to go kind of other
way say here's something factor that we
know biologically and this is how it
differentiates in the living space so I
don't know Mike Holly we can like so you
want a scale what like to get the
underlying are the structure level of
the autoencoder to learn sure I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
structuring the trajectory or manifolds
or however you want to describe it Emily
yes that is that are way too like
interrogate that structure to learn
something about biology this is sort of
to your second future point where I'm
hearing what your approach is community
yes so you need one I think that so we
have we're seen this trajectory or
medical learning but we can see like how
the gene expression levels are
progressing in that trajectory and see
is there any distinct change in the
expression that we are seeing and that
maybe that can be a insightful biology
and it kind it can probably so we know
our signature genes that is that is a
particular to some developmental process
or disease process or something but that
Saku learning that trajectory that might
also point us to new type new genes that
we didn't know that is actually playing
a role in this particular process of
after learning the trajectory maybe we
can find more about those kind of genes
that were not previously experimental
interests
so that is what immediate think that
comes to my mind but then again yeah
I didn't understand some part of it so
if you have a deeper tree as far as how
the cells are evolving and finality is
kind of deeper it seemed like there were
only really two like what would be the
depth of the tree for the datasets that
you use as far as you know so um so the
depth of the tree is actually we so the
depth already actually comes
automatically from the autoencoder
projection so we don't have like any
parameters to control like accounting of
the tree that mean so some cases that
for example so here for the expression
it is for some of them we see two branch
things but for some of them we don't say
for example here this malignant since
there is actually one line so it's just
it's not maybe there is not like two
distinct cell population it's just
showing a trajectory of one so it's like
so it's Trevor it's developing
trajectory or something maybe it's not
there is no differentiation same goes
for for this particular astrocytoma
datasets here most of the cells are in
one particular plot which is more
intermediates because it's not
differentiated well enough so it's the
depth of are the depth of the tree it's
not that we are controlling it's what
the auto encoder is learning on itself
how could you how would you change the
structure to capture the
I mean it presumably in the data
probably yeah so our intuition is that
auto-encoder if it's working good it
should be able to if there is any deeper
branching of the cells it should be able
to capture it so that is our intuition
we haven't found we haven't tested any
data set that had like a deeper yeah so
yeah so we can like so there's also we
need we want to investigate more latent
variables later to see whether our
intuition is that different ligand our
dimensions may capture different aspect
of the key more probability the sub
property some maybe some cells are
coming from a different micro
environment maybe that is reflected on
that or not so I might ensure at least
my inclusion was something like that
more little dimensions might capture
more more tumor cell properties then we
are saying here's things like cell cycle
effects that is kind of yeah our job so
uh so this is so one way to account for
the cell cycle effects it's like if you
exclude the genes that are known for
cell cycle being active for cell cycle
we haven't done anything like we haven't
excluded any genes based on any prior
knowledge including everything
okay well thank you everybody thank you
[Applause]